[Applause]
[Music]
straight audience wow what a great group
of people we have great to see you all
how are you
these are all my rowdy friends the only
normal people in New York City Welcome
to Hannity welcome to all of you at home
thank you for joining us and tonight a
flagrant double standard in our great
country the US of a if you are Donald
Trump or if you are a trump supporter
you are not allowed to ever dare
question election results if you do
there will be a special prosecutor in
Atlanta or an Atlanta D.A that might try
to put you in prison to the day you die
as a matter of fact he's facing all just
791 years when you add all the counts up
together uh murderers they spend five
minutes in jail Donald Trump they put in
jail lock them up throw away the key but
if you're a Democrat never Trumper
member of the media mob you pretty much
do and say anything you want and we've
got the tape to prove it Senator Marco
Rubio actually tweeted this out from a
group associated with journalist Matt
taibi you know the guy from Twitter take
a look my biggest fear is that he's
gonna do it again with the help of Vlad
his best past terrifying would you be my
vice presidential candidate Donald Trump
is an illegitimate president
this wasn't on the level yes Trump
cheated Trump cheated the 2016 election
he's an illegitimate president anger at
what some see as an illegitimate
president
a number of incidents turned violent
protesters hurled trash cans flash bombs
and objects at police several officers
injured protesters grew rocks and
smashed Windows leading to more
confrontations injuries and arrests the
chaotic scene just blocks outside the
secure area of the inauguration you may
have seen it on social media more than
four million people have signed a
petition focusing on Hillary Clinton's
lead in the popular vote they're holding
on to Hope asking members of The
Electoral College to back Clinton
instead of trump
okay now you got a democratic media mob
the only candidate by the way who
colluded with Russia we found out in
2016 was Hillary Clinton when she paid
for a dirty Russian disinformation
dossier paid for by an ex-foreign spy
and first used against Donald Trump in
that election and then of course to
delegitimize Donald Trump after the
election illegitimate illegitimate
illegitimate they took out the part of
the tape that I wanted anyway we can get
that to you later in the show Hillary
Clinton never faced legal consequences
none of the Democrats who objected to
the 2016 results uh and attempted to
discredit our elections they'd ever face
consequences whatsoever even the people
involved in efforts uh that literally
were calling for alternate electors in
2016. they've faced zero consequences
very few of the violent anti-trump
rioters were ever charged with the crime
uh even Those Who attack Federal
courthouses lighting him on fire night
after night after night in Portland
574 riots summer of 2020 we had two
dozen Americans dead thousands of cops
pelted with Rick bricks bottles Molotov
cocktails You Name It 2 000 cops injured
nobody held accountable billions in
property damage nobody held accountable
in Georgia want to be Governor Stacy
Abrams she frequently accused
Republicans of stealing the 2018
gubernatorial election and she pressured
State officials to action against
Phantom vote voter suppression claims
and she refused as we all know to
concede for years but no charges out of
Atlanta against Stacey Abrams you decide
if this is equal justice under the law
this is not a speech of concession was
the election in Georgia Statewide a free
and fair election
it was not a free and fair election
Cliff said you know she lost I'm like no
I just didn't win because we don't know
what really happened because of the
miasma of voter suppression for me
concession there's a legal and moral
nature to conceding it means you accept
that something is right that it is just
that it is proper what happened was not
just I may not have won this election or
at least but I didn't lose I got the
votes but we won't know exactly how many
because of how they cheated we had this
little election back in 2018.
and despite the final tally and the
inauguration and the situation we find
ourselves in I do have one very
affirmative statement to make
we won
I believe
was a stolen election and I'm not saying
they stole it from me they stole it from
the voters of Georgia again if you are a
prominent Democrat you can pretty much
do whatever you want because the liberal
lawyers that dominate what is now a
weaponized doj
uh Joe Biden's doj they will have your
back in fact they're going to even run
your campaign while you enjoy some rest
and relaxation at the beach and allow me
to explain remember soon after Joe Biden
he will now soon embark on a leisurely
trip to Lake Tahoe in California uh this
is shortly after his weekend at the
Beach in Delaware which by the way it
wasn't a week week and a half ago he was
on a 10-day vacation on the beach and it
was having a hard time dragging his his
beach chair around him but tonight Joe
Biden's reelection strategy that is in
full gear he doesn't need to lift the
finger why because this election season
he's going to allow his own Department
of Justice and the justice system to do
all the heavy lifting for him on March
14th Donald Trump I'm sorry March 4th
Donald Trump well according to the
filing down in Atlanta they want to
start that trial in Atlanta on March the
4th well the very next day lo and behold
what a coin incidents that would be
March 5th and that will also be super
Tuesday Donald Trump will also face a
court date to be determined during the
campaign season in Washington D.C one in
Florida and one in New York and while
Donald Trump gets non-stop negative
press Joe Biden he'll just remain in
hiding just like he did in 2020 in the
media mob candidate Protection Program
that's what they offer him the greatest
campaign contribution anybody running
for president could ever want or need as
a matter of fact over the past few
months every time a Biden scandal
emerged well Trump suddenly faced a new
legal challenge ask yourself is this a
mere coincidence June 7th the FBI
finally gives Congress that 1023 form
they had to of course threaten uh to
bring in Christopher Ray and hold them
in contempt to Congress because he
wouldn't hand it over that was the one
that documented form bribery allegations
against Joe Biden and Hunter Biden from
that credible FBI Source because the FBI
had paid this guy hundreds of thousands
of dollars the very next day June the
8th doj special counsel Jack Smith
indicts Trump in the Mar-A-Lago document
case then on July 26th Hunter Biden's
unprecedented sweetheart deal with the
doj was introduced in court and then
rejected by that federal judge who did a
great job the very next day July 27th ah
look at this uh the special counsel
added even more charges on to Donald
Trump's Mar-A-Lago case mere
coincidences right and then on July 31st
Hunter Biden's former business partner
that would be Devin Archer testified
before Congress and in fact Joe Biden
Not only was on phone calls with some of
Hunter Biden and Devin's business
partners some 20 calls but he also met
them in person a number of times Cafe
Milano and the very next day after that
well that would be August 1st well here
we go again this special counsel
indicted Trump once again over the
January 6th issue in Washington D.C
which brings us to Last Friday when a
sham special counsel was appointed a
slow walk the hunter Biden investigation
and cover up misconduct at the
Department of Justice the very next
working day that would go from Friday to
Monday and then we got you got it new
charges against Donald Trump this time
out of Atlanta it's crazy how that all
works out I'm sure does everyone agree
with me those are mere coincidences
right you all agree oh you're all oh
okay thank you
the mob in the media is once again
obsessing over Donald Trump 24 7 365 and
Joe Biden is daughtering along under the
radar today during his brief remarks
about the devastation in Maui he
couldn't even remember the name of the
island this is after he wouldn't even
comment uh no comment uh what do you
have to say to the people of Hawaii no
comment really did he not know what was
going on in by the way the name is Maui
Joe anyway take a look
the army helicopters help fire
suppression and efforts on the big
island
because there's still some burning on
the big island not the ones that not the
one where you see on television all the
time
the media mob's covering for that guy
Biden says that he can't go to Hawaii
quite yet because he believes he's just
going to be in the way now how do we
know that that's an outright lie well
everything is already gone Joe have you
not seen the devastation that our fellow
Americans have been going through in
Maui and Hawaii all the homes and
businesses burn to the ground Joe a
short visit to the island I promise you
you're not going to get in the way
because nobody's there they've all had
to evacuate they've all lost their homes
they've all lost their life's investment
and we're still missing as many as 1300
people over 105 people already confirmed
dead look at the devastation you think
you're going to get in the way there
there's nobody there it would help if
Biden actually you know was giving the
Hawaiian people the aid that they need
to quickly recover Joe is committed well
okay seven hundred dollars per household
in Maui by the way in Ukraine the people
there have received over 2 twenty six
hundred dollars in Aid per person from
Biden so far does that seem right to you
anyway does it
but unlike you know President Bush and
Katrina or president Trump and the media
mob going after him over Puerto Rico
there'll be no negative coverage of Joe
Biden they're too busy talking about
Donald Trump obsessively compulsively
and the dozens of new charges that he
faces and it's all according to plan hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else